[Inaudible].
Crystal clear waters,
endless beaches and passable jungles landscapes that take us to the very heart
of what the word paradise means. My friends, this is the Philippines,
a remote and little known country that has nevertheless had a significant
historical connection with both Spain and somehow with many of Latin America's
Hispanic countries as well.
[Inaudible].
This former Spanish colony and Southeast Asia was for more than three centuries
parts of the Spanish empire. Then after the defeat of Spanish troops in 1898,
by those of the United States,
the Philippines were sold to the U S for $20 million with adjustments for
inflation that works out to about $620 million in today's money. Yes,
at that time, the colonies were sold as if they were plots of beachfront land.
Of course, in this case,
the sale and price were practically determined by the United States.
After all they had just won the war and they had the biggest guns
Of course,
far from gaining independence or at least improving its independence with the
United States leading the way freedom for Filipinos. Ironically did not come
After being sold to the Americans.
The Philippines was governed by the us for nearly five decades until finally in
1946, the gained their actual independence since then,
the trajectory of this country has not exactly been a bed of roses,
but rather it's been a bunch of thorns, dictatorships, corruption, violence,
drug trafficking, Islamism,
the Philippines manages to bring together a bit of all of the worst problems
that lurk and countries as far away as Venezuela, Honduras, and Pakistan,
and to combat this, no, they have detected
Rodrigo.
Duterte is currently the Philippine president and despite being democratically
elected, let's just say there's little to no sign of democracy. In fact,
it's pretty much the opposite. Check out.
Philippine mayor on Duterte narco list shot dead.
The straits times a slaughter them policy that targets the Philippines
poor Al-Jazeera president Rodrigo Duterte war on drugs policy
has led to more than 20,000 deaths since 2016.
Okay, so we are talking about full-blown extra judicial executions. In fact,
the Philippine government has actually leaked.
So do you want to know more about this far away country?
Do you want to know more about the dark figure of Rodrigo Duterte?
So if you do and why wouldn't you listen up.
The Philippines, a country of the best and worst.
First off, this is about to get pretty heavy.
So I think to start off with it would be a good idea. Get to know the country.
We're talking about a little better and our,
to tell you that we're talking about a very unusual country. On one hand,
we're talking about the first country in all of Asia to have a constitution
approved by a partially elected Congress.
So a good thing that happened all the way back in the late 19th century and the
short periods between the end of Spanish rule and the U S invasion,
there was a short-lived unrecognized Republic known internationally as the
Republic.
[Inaudible].
Of course, after paying $20 million for these islands,
the Americans were very clear that this territory belonged to them.
So they had no qualms about using all the force necessary to end the
self-proclaimed Republic and the sort of ironic twist that only history can give
us any support for the independence cause was considered a criminal activity by
the U S and in 1906,
American troops arrested and executed members of the last government of the
Republic, including its president general Makarios. A key.
Death will come to us all sooner or later.
So I will stand calmly before the Lord almighty,
but I want to tell you that we are not bandaids or thieves as the Americans have
accused us, but members of the revolutionary force that defended our motherland,
the Philippines long-lived democracy,
and hopefully our independence will be reborn in the future.
Long lived the Philippines Makarios soccer. So.
The Philippines is an extremely diverse country to give you an idea it's 110
million inhabitants speak 170 different languages.
That is a bigger mess than my teeth. And yet that's not as big as problem,
not by a long.
Despite.
The fact that up until the coronavirus crisis,
this country had gone 20 years without suffering a single quarter of negative
growth. And even though over the last decade,
the average economic growth has been almost 6% per year.
The Philippines remains a very poor country,
a country where the majority of the population remains anchored in absolute
poverty.
This is a country where the average salary is just over $200 per month.
And we're one of the main sources of wealth is the nearly $30 billion.
The more than 12 million Filipinos around the world transfer and remittances to
their families.
Yeah.
If we consider the problems that the government has controlling a country made
up of more than 7,000 islands per infrastructure on 170 different languages,
then we faint.
It is the perfect breeding ground for the emergence of non-recommended
activities.
So.
Visual politics, poverty,
and lack of control by the government and the legal system over a large part of
the country has made the Philippines.
One of the biggest Asian epicenters for human trafficking and also for drug
trafficking.
The Philippines is not only the largest consumer of methamphetamines and
marijuana in Eastern Asia, but also its largest producer.
And do you know where most of the cocktails operating in the country come from,
they come from China and you can get an idea of what this might entail.
And other countries where these mafias exist,
violence and lack of security are a huge problem around all of these narcotic
mafias. A whole web of illegal economies have also been created dedicated to the
trafficking of people,
organs smuggling of all kinds and practically any other criminal activity that
you can think of. Of course,
going hand in hand with this corruption is almost institutionalized as one more
economic.
[Inaudible].
As you can probably imagine.
Poverty has forced many families to have to throw themselves into the arms of
one of the many underworld groups operating in the country.
And it is against this backdrop as we shall see,
but the figure of Duterte arises a present basically characterized by two
things, a heavy hand as an,
a very hard lane against grain and promises of economic growth for the latter.
He means to clear the deck and switch strategic.
Partners.
For many years, the Philippines had been very close to the United States,
obviously so much so that Washington has come to classify its relationship with
the Philippines as special.
And the nation is considered one of its most important strategic allies in Asia,
along with countries, such as Taiwan, South Korea, or Thailand
As president Duterte, his arrival in 2016,
the Manila Washington access has been increasingly veering to Beijing,
especially over the past.
Look. And you can see what changed. There has been.
May, 2017 do terat says China's sea threatened war it.
Philippines drills for oil Reuters, April, 2018,
Philippines president Rodrigo Duterte says he needs China loves CGMP,
CNN. I mean China, more than anybody else at this point, I need China.
I simply love CGM ping. He understood.
He understands my problem and is willing to help. So I would say thank you,
tryna Rodrigo Duterte, president of the Philippines.
All else do territory wants money, investment,
and as much Chinese capital as possible to lift the country's economy.
He couldn't be more transparent about it. Check this.
Our destiny lies in Asia, not in the middle East, as they're too busy fighting,
and they don't have any money. And if you don't have money,
you're not my friend. So I go to China, plenty of money, president Duterte,
are you kidding?
Just surprised at such sincerity because honestly you probably shouldn't be
Duterte as anything, but a normal president.
And.
In a way it is quite logical that he should get along better with dictators like
Zhang Peng than with the leaders of Western democracies. So what's the reason,
well, wasn't it.
[Inaudible].
The toughest resident.
If anything has characterized Rodrigo Duterte since the beginning of his
presidency is that he is the president who speaks plainly and who does not mess
around. Let's just say that if we were talking about scruples,
he has absolutely none.
He is willing to do whatever it takes to fight not only trafficking and
criminals, but also his own political adversaries. In fact,
his harsh ways of [inaudible] fame around the world for being a dictator and a
tyrant and for not respecting even the most basic of human rights take,
for example, what happens during the SARS cov.
Crisis.
They promised to enforce quarantines completely at any cost. Listen.
Do Terrance response to the coronavirus, shoot them dead foreign policy.
My orders to the police and military,
if there trouble or the situation rises where your life is on the line,
shoot the dead understand dead. I'll send you to the grave.
Don't test the government Rodrigo Duterte.
So two days after these statements,
a sexy three-year-old farmer was shot by police for not wearing a mask.
According to the agents, the man threatened them with a safe proportionality.
What the hell is that? Anyway, and there's environment.
There has been an increase in shootings of civilians by police across the
country. Something that is not covered up at all by law enforcement.
And he went out at the wrong time will be shot.
You sons of Philippine police officer in a radio report.
And that is not all following the government's own orders.
And some municipalities people who were caught skipping curfews have been locked
in dog cages and other places punishments have also been applied that could
easily be mistaken for torture. Of course, this kind of thing.
Didn't start with.
Virus.
You texted him as a guy who simply does not believe in reintegration,
according to him, as he has expressed many times,
those who commit crimes are nothing more than expendable social waste.
That is precisely why Duterte established a zero tolerance policy against drug
traffickers and narcotics consumers. Since his arrival in power,
he has also ordered a shoot.
Policy.
Look, consider this for just one moment,
despite all of this being a clear violation of the most basic human rights,
what the Philippines has experienced.
It tells us that this tough approach is not the best way to fake crane.
And what did he already has done is simply to set in motion a whole machinery of
extra judicial executions as given the police many public officials and their
own government, the ability to get rid of people with total impunity.
And this is in a country with very high levels of corruption. And.
Let me.
Ask you a simple question. Would you dare and an environment like this,
oppose the government or denounced the wheelings and dealings of for example,
a corrupt police officer. I bet.
Yes.
Since the first zero tolerance policy was launched,
or perhaps we should call that the zero legality policy,
at least 6,600 people are estimated to have lost their lives in the
Philippines, according to the police. However, that number,
according to human rights,
watch goes all the way up to 27,000 people to top it all off.
Many of those people had nothing to do with drug trafficking or mafias or any
criminal activity at all,
but they were simply people who were caught in the crossfire or corruption or
for some other reasons.
So.
At this point, how do you think that Philippine residents rate their presidents?
Well, contrary to what you might think, Rodrigo Duterte,
his popularity is around AC that's right.
80% is a little bit less than complete favor,
but how on earth can a guy like that achieve these levels of.
Yeah.
May seem hard to accept and our culture, but a nation hit by crane, narcotics,
trafficking, human trafficking and poverty. It's no wonder that for many people,
things like freedom and human rights are left far in the background. Indeed.
According to polls, only 15% of residents consider democracy to be essential.
And even for us in the West,
some of this might be starting to send creepily familiar in the end.
What we have already seen happen many other times happens despair,
disappointment and corruption are often the best ways to feed authoritarian.
Leaders.
Anyway, it's your turn.
Now as a president like Duterte entitled to pass on human rights,
even if he pursues an end,
that theoretically could be good as the fight against crime,
more important than the law and justice.
Do you think you would like someone like Duterte in your country before I say to
you about the comments, this has been a pretty heavy video.
So why don't you give your pet a little pots,
give your mom a hug and get yourself a nice cup of tea so that we can all feel
better. Anyway, leave your comments here below. And if you like this video,
don't forget to give us a like subscribe to our channel and you can keep
yourself up-to-date with everything that has to come by clicking on the little
lung button down there. Thanks for tuning in. We'll see you next time.
And if you want to learn more about politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice, you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsidermedia.com slash podcast. See you there.
[Inaudible].